[Laughter]
[Music]
all right this is gonna be a really
tough one to guess I'll be surprised if
any of you even get close bar will do it
there is uh so over in the Hunan
Province in China
[Laughter]
unani Province there's a there's an
interesting food that's getting like a
lot of attention
apparently it's centuries old they sell
it out of a food stall and it was
something that boat men ate when they
didn't have any food
what
what was it like not even food like it's
a food they ate when they didn't have
food what the hell do you think they
could be is it edible the boat the
pieces of the boat yeah as I slowly
single
it's not pieces of the boat leather bags
special food it's edible no it's not
it's not it because you know that's what
they did back in the day when um when
when sailors like explore they ate the
bag they would eat the leather paper the
leather there's nutrition in it how many
calories is in leather probably like 50
grams of protein dude
isn't that like chicharrones like it's
kind of yeah it's
just dried out oh yeah it's dried out
yeah then fried with chemicals and they
put stuff on it and paint what do you
think flowers flowers is that there's
actually a good [__] thing
it's not mud but it's it's close you're
not too far off bugs just
it's not that it rhymed with mud
yeah
it's not mud it's um is that close sand
or Rock it's cool
rocks which one which one do you want to
commit to one I think it's sand you say
sand he says rocks oh which one do you
think it is one of you is right I think
it's sand because you can mix it with a
little bit of water dude and it goes
down real nice that's genius it's
actually rocks
crazy
little rocks
stir-fried rocks stir-fry they ate that
in the Hunan Province apparently
hundreds of years ago yeah is it a
specific kind of they're very smooth
okay
now we're talking yeah it's weird like
are we talking about River Pebbles
yeah they seasoned rocks right and they
season it
oh I've actually seen this before
really
got food they're making rocks of food
it's a garnish so you're not supposed to
actually eat the rock you're just
supposed to like suck on it yeah there's
suck rocks dude I'll suck on a rock yeah
so are they eating like the green onions
or whatever on the rock yeah well it
looks like they just like sauteed and
all this stuff to give it flavor and
then you just suck the Rock and then
toss it yeah but you throw us for a loop
because you said eat I mean yeah
technically they are eating yeah they're
sucking them but that's kind of like
getting crawfish because you just
basically have half a centimeter of food
and they just lick the [__] out of the
shell yeah but it's like
it's like people are really voluntarily
trying to get these dude what a [__]
cash grab this maybe it tastes good
right
endless rocks
and Postmates delivery man's worst
nightmare
[Laughter]
so there's saute with uh stir-fried with
garlic chili uh Rosemary to give it that
distinct flavor oh good Rosemary rocks I
think
costs about 223. dude save it
hey that's the market price at Home
Depot
will you lose
dude
on your lawn dude on your life they look
nice
oh it isn't like the Fishbowl yeah yeah
at least there's no food waste you all
you gotta do is just saute it and stir
fry it again
reusable that's the part that's weird as
they are like they are saying that they
say that after you're done sucking it
you give it a good give it back to me
yeah and exactly and then they'll go and
get the Rocks again and re-surf right
this is a high margin business dude yeah
but yeah they're printing the game of it
is it's
s-u-o-d-i-u how do you say that
s-o-u-s-u-o s-u-o-d-i-u
so do you
see I don't even know how do you say
rock
okay so the it says the translation is
to suck and throw away how do you say
that oh to suck oh okay so the DIA is
still
suck is I don't know what sucks she oh
maybe that's how you say she deal
she should do you trying to suck and
throw it away
Nick's pretty good at that not the
throwaway part I get real attached
I just can't help it I just love too
hard
but yeah I guess it's like a it's a it's
a good thing to pair with wine
apparently no it's not
what did they say that they told her
like trying to figure out if he's weird
or not yeah this is a famine pleasure
right here because it's all just liquid
like you got [__] alcohol and then
that just makes you forget that you're
hungry and you're just sucking on it's
like a mirage food yeah it's basically
like you get the satiation or the
feeling of but you're just it's like
food from Hook
someone's gonna suck on this too hard
and it's gonna that's what I'm saying to
the back of the throat they already
warned people not to do that
they really did they're like don't
swallow the Rocks I wonder if there's a
technique you know how like uh like all
your parents like if you get like a big
old like steak or ham or turkey or
whatever they're like oh get that piece
that piece is good I wonder if they like
get the small rocks the flavor someone
almost body for the small rock with a
big rock or or if you can like suck it
wrong potluck parties you're gonna bring
who got the Rocks who's gonna bring the
what a jib dude don't invite the rock
guy don't fight that guy he always
brings rocks over the table
rocks they should do dessert rocks I'm
into that dessert whipped cream on some
rocks like condensed milk a little
shaved dog fondue
foreign
[Laughter]
what is the uh proper dinner party way
of sucking a rock glad you probably have
to be very dainty with it go ahead you
probably have to show hold on
[Laughter]
imagine imagine the Governor's Ball go
ahead yeah it's pretty good oh it's good
do it with a piece of Mochi here rip rip
one of them little round guys off oh
yeah do the demo with that you suck on
that so that way you can actually like
show us there's no Oreo dude you just
call it got cinnamon this guy dude
losing his touch I want to see how this
is supposed to look at a fine dinner
party so you gotta eat with one hand in
Upstate New York you gotta eat with one
hand all right and then you know like
they'll have like a napkin because it's
like a it's a oh that's nice
yeah yeah and you're like oh thank you
okay cool that's very good like oh it's
good hot rocks and then now suck it okay
what do you taste I taste uh garlic
I taste uh River Bottom vegetable oil
vegetable
pants of bamboo shoots and ginger oh
what and then you're like oh I'm gonna
yeah and then as you're talking you find
a a pause in the conversation okay and
then you
[Laughter]
help him help him sir I'm lick it's a
natural reaction now he's choking on his
Rocco yeah
that's how you do the heimlich real
classy idiots
[Laughter]
so you don't think they're going to sell
this at the 66 Night Market
I don't I honestly don't think we have
the rocks for it I think people will buy
anything these days if it's a big
novelty I feel like oh you know what's
funny though you've never been to like
those sweet factory candy stores at the
mall yeah they would have a bucket of
like candy that's like candy rocks
everybody oh yeah okay yeah are good
like sugar yeah I feel like they should
just but that's edible right yeah that's
yeah and also who's buying candy rocks
by the way grandmas I don't even think
Grandma they're biting but they're like
chewable huh I don't know I've never
bought them and I have no interest hey
you know what if Grand Central Market in
Downtown LA has a peanut butter and
jelly restaurant that's survived
pandemic yeah then rocks are not too no
that's not this is it good have they had
it from there I've never had it I just
see it ever it's just peanut butter
jelly and I look at it and I go
they made it good
[Music]
foreign